way back in 1991 our next guest was
flinging it down the field at the skills
competition look at that one i think
that was for the win right the
bull's-eye for the win season that was
the winner yeah yeah that was the win
right there there it is
yeah that was the quarterback challenge
that was in hawaii which was always a
lot of fun you take your family out
there get to throw the ball around a
little bit and yeah so i i won it all in
that last throw sometimes you got to
make a throw
that was that was that was the same year
that was when you beat steve de berg on
that throne yeah i believe yes you beat
steve de berg in the playoff game i
believe that year too right yeah yes
yeah he had a rough month
how is steve de berg even in that
competition though no disrespect to
steve berg but he's not one of the best
quarterbacks of the era especially in 91
i know so he was a member because he was
about i think because he played so long
he's he was in it yeah i i got to catch
a pass of dan at quarterback challenges
when i was there with my dad as a young
kid i like but before dan would go out
and do the competition he would like
chris get over there and he's throwing
me some we got to warm up yeah warm up a
little bit real quick and i was like i
i'm catching them i mean screw phil
serious
i'm touching that's my man
marine
so how old was he the first time you
encountered this
[Laughter]
it when you see all these guys now you
got drew brees throwing for 5 000 yards
every other year i mean your record
stood for years before brees broke
how many yards would you have in today's
game with today's rules so the best part
about this is i don't have to prove it
so i'm going to say like 6 000 60
touchdowns
but uh it is i would say it is probably
a lot easier to throw it now and people
are throwing it more too so that's
another factor as far as you know the
yards and and there's you know the run
after catch the whole thing the bubble
screens they're usually like we didn't
do it we didn't get
yeah we didn't do a lot of that stuff
yeah you know you throw a screen but not
the bubble screens like they do now yeah
i i've always made that defense with you
and guys like john elway because you
know peyton manning at the end of his
career he's be nine for ten you go maybe
he can throw a ball for over five yards
to start the game saw in the line of
scrimmage and that wasn't part of uh his
game in general but i mean i i think the
big thing too at what point of your
career did you feel like your arm was
just in peak like physical condition and
what at what point of your career did
you feel like it started to go like oh
okay damn i gotta start probably yeah
you know what i felt pretty good about
throwing the ball throughout my my whole
career really what you know stopped for
me was my legs you know being able to
get the drops i wanted the timing in my
drops um right but my arm even after i
retired i felt like i could still sling
it around pretty good and throw it you
know and i think that's you know you
look at all the quarterbacks as time
goes on if they can keep their laziness
legs in shape and i mean brady's only
had really one bad injury you know drew
brees has always been able to move
around pretty good and aaron rodgers and
as long as that's there they're going to
be able to throw the football do you
think it's like the quarterback rules do
you ever look and go man i think i could
have played five more years if they had
all these rules to protect the
quarterback at that point there would
have been some less hits that's for sure
yeah you know there's no doubt and uh
the rules have changed and that and you
know i can understand it you want to try
to keep your quarterbacks healthy
because they're such a big part of the
game and
and uh as far as just
you know the the franchise i mean that's
the guy you you know you're relying on
each and every week so you want to keep
them healthy i understand the rules part
but it is totally different yeah we were
talking earlier about the patriots
possibly getting to a point at some
point coming up where they have to make
a decision as to whether or not they're
going to keep tom brady with tom brady
play somewhere else you had an
opportunity to play in minnesota after
you were done in miami how close did you
come to doing that pretty close you know
i did i really thought about it also i
could have went to pittsburgh too and
that would have been that would have
been something i would hope bill coward
called me a couple days after you know i
was
was a free agent and
uh so i thought about it and uh i just
think it was
some of the health issues some uh
leaving my kids going up there changing
schools all that stuff so you know that
that was probably more of a factor
i probably could have played a couple
more years if you went to minnesota
fanboy over here
he would have had your jersey
if you didn't have a good year though
you might he might have really hated on
you too yeah you never know kirk yeah
her cousins won't come on this weekend
kirk cousins kirk cousins is coming
nowhere near this stage i won't let him
um
did he bug you that the steelers didn't
draft you was that something that you
carried around in your head for a while
um
you know i think in general when you
look back because i thought i would be
picked higher than i was yeah so you
know it's like yeah you want to show
these guys hey i should have been picked
but uh i didn't carry it around long you
know it's one of those things i was
fortunate to go to miami with a team
that just came from the super bowl year
before they lost so we had some players
you know and it i think it helped me my
as far as my young career was concerned
and how i developed pretty quickly and
then you got to beat him in an afc
championship game yeah i'm sure that's
how you're like all right he eat that
yeah and jack lambert was on that team
and yeah bonnie shell yeah he's pretty
cool all right go ahead and watch it
sorry uh the
young quarterback in the league right
now i mean patrick mahomes had a dan
marino year this year i mean second year
50 touchdowns 5 000 yards i mean what's
your impressions of him uh he's excited
to watch you know he's you know when you
looked at him in college and looked at
him on tape he's like wow this kid's you
know he's throwing it from the hip he's
throwing at all different arm angles and
going down the field and and uh i i just
enjoy watching him i love watching
quarterback play like that when he feels
like he can make any throw at any time i
mean it's uh it's pretty cool to watch
why do you think more teams weren't on
him two years ago you know it wasn't
really clear where he was going to go in
round one there was a cluster of guys
entering deshaun watson where he's going
to go where's mahomes gonna go where's
trubisky going to go and now in
hindsight you know you find out there
were several teams that were kind of
secretly like we really really really
wanted this guy why wasn't he regarded
by everyone as a can't miss prospect i
don't i think sometimes you know you
over analyze things as like as far as
you know technique and you know you know
because the way his style played maybe
that's what it was you know oh well he
sometimes he doesn't you know square his
body up to throwing out you know that's
he throws it across his body but at the
end of the day it's about results and
that kid can make throws from from any
angle and and uh so so maybe they just
you know maybe over over coach it or
over analyzing yeah right and plus it's
texas tech and they're all scared of
that like oh gosh this is the offense
whatever it is he's throwing some bubble
screens
but he can throw anything well with my
homes you throw everything out the
window that you ever thought about a
quarterback it doesn't matter if you
have a base it doesn't matter if you do
the drop perfectly it doesn't matter if
your hips are right that guy can put his
arm in any position from here down to
here
and and make the throw even if we had to
throw 50 yards down the field no feet
were on the ground it wasn't the wrong
foot it was no feet he was completely in
the air but he's got so much strength in
that arm he can do he can get away with
anything yeah that's what i was saying i
mean that's the that and then maybe
that's why he didn't you know get the
play as being a top five pick or
something but at the same time he makes
it makes it work when you think of like
when you think of great throwers of all
time just when you just who are the
names that first come come to your mind
like where you just go just talk about
the throwing aspect because you are
without a doubt one of the most gifted
throwers quickest releases beautiful
spiral you want me to keep going yeah
keep going
i mean there was nothing like as a young
kid watching you just sling the ball
around so i i mean to me elway was
someone that always you know just can
flat out throw it and throw it deep to
make all the throws with velocity and
accuracy and uh joe montana didn't have
the big arm but man he had the he had he
had the velocity and the accuracy and
all that stuff and i guess as a kid
growing up i mean grew up as a steeler
fan so you know terry bradshaw was a guy
and uh joe joe namath back in the day
loved watching you know joe played and
his style play western pa guys yes yes
and then um today it's aaron rodgers i
mean aaron rodgers can just flat out
throw it man he's like you i feel like
his emotions a lot like he gets out
quick yeah and he got vlad you got
everything yeah right i'm with you there
before we let you go you got a product
that i need to know about after a week
of junk food and going out to every
restaurant and then super sunday in the
press box with all the food i'm getting
a little soft i know so tell me what i
need to start on monday first of all
it's nutrisystem and i've been working
with them for 13 years and it's uh it's
about men's dieting and nutrisystem for
men actually in the day after the super
bowl monday is called super monday is
the biggest uh diet decision day for men
uh during the year so so think about
nutrisystem i lost 22 pounds on it uh
it's been a great relationship for a lot
of years so nutrisystem for men yes
super monday i'm i'm going to need it
myself all right we're going into what
we're calling this the fish bowl but
since it's you we'll call it the dolphin
bowl okay yeah go ahead we're just
random find out he wrote the questions
so god only knows what's coming out of
those questions
i don't have my glasses oh i can read it
for you that's good this is great i'm
reading for dan marino where would you
like to retire and why i think he's
already there yeah yeah
retirement so
i don't think you ever want to retire
you always want to do something and be
active and and be involved in some way
uh
uh so yeah what i would retire uh yeah
right where i'm at fort lauderdale yeah
yeah yeah
that was too easy yeah that was that was
wait wait wait we got a minute left but
you're really not retired because you're
helping the dolphins now how hard is it
for you to help the dolphins find the
next dan marina oh um that's a tough
question because uh you know i did have
a lot of success there and um it's so
important nowadays uh to to have a guy
that you know you can rely on each and
every week and and ryan's been our guy
for a long time
you know we'll see where that goes with
a new coach and you know you don't know
what that's going to be uh but uh i feel
you know it was tough on him the past
couple years because of his injuries you
know because he was you know really
playing at a really high level there
when he started to get hurt yeah
well dan we appreciate you as always
we'll check out your system and i mean
it's going to be time for it
i always i always get in the rings
discussion right and i always defend you
because i hate that crap and i guess oh
and he does too are we going to say phil
sims is better than dan marino if he's
got a ring
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports